Hello and welcome, everyone.
It is June 13th, 2022,
and we're here in Acton Lab.
Guest stream number 23.1
with Maxwell and Dalton.
We're talking about
rebooting the three energy principal
literature and their recent publication.
So I'll pass it to the two of you
to provide
just an initial introduction
and some context for the paper.
Before we jump into some specific parts.
Maxwell First.
Cool.
My name is Maxwell Ramstad.
I am the director of research
at the Viruses Research Lab,
where we specialize
in probabilistic approaches
to artificial intelligence
and of late, most of my research
has been on the physics
foundations of the free energy principle.
And I'm very,
very much looking forward
to having this conversation.
Awesome. And Dalton.
Sure.
Okay. Well, I'm Dalton.
I'm a mathematician and physicist.
So right
now, I'm I'm at Stony
Brook University in New York.
I'm also at the verses lab
where we're doing
some work on the free energy principle.
Right now,
my research interests are about formal
approaches to biological physics
and mathematical foundations of complex
systems and these kinds of questions.
One of the most interesting
frameworks in this sphere is the free
energy principle, and that's how
I've gotten involved in this literature.
Awesome.
So maybe in the same order,
what brought us to this paper?
What was the gap
that this paper stepped into
and how did this team arise
around the paper?
And I'll bring it up on the screen
as well.
Good question.
Well, I think the paper does
a bunch of different things.
The first I mean, we've presented this
as rebooting the free energy
principle literature.
I think
over the last it's
been almost two decades
now since the FFP has been a thing.
I think the first paper was circa
2005 ish
and the framework
or the the field of study
that has emerged around the free energy
principle has changed a lot over the last
two decades, in no small part
in terms of the self-understanding
that we have
as a community of practitioners
working with these techniques.
And I mean,
as they pointed out a while back,
I think the last time that really
the Occupy literature had been surveyed
in a systematic fashion
to kind of present where we were at,
where we are, kind of like State of
the Art was probably Karl's
monograph from 2019th January 2019.
I mean, you know, both of you were part
of this international physics
reading group that we had.
This was not
this is not a simple piece to read. And
yet, since then, there hasn't really been
basically a summary
of where the literature is.
So on the one hand,
we were aiming to reboot the literature
to to basically summarize
the ways that the free energy
principle had been applied
in the literature and
to also present a lot of the progress
that had been made over
the last three years,
a lot of which is due to Delta.
So I think that Segways
nicely into the it's a download
well.
Too generous by far as usual.
But yeah.
So Maxwell raises a good point that there
hasn't been really
an effort to tie together
all the different threads
since probably 2019.
And one of the reasons why
I mean, that's that's a long time,
but it's not overly long.
However, in the last couple of years,
there have been some pretty
serious advances in the state
of the mathematics and the physics
behind the free energy principle.
So now, you know, three years
later, we're in 2022, it's
not a long time.
But nevertheless, there have been
big developments that really
beg this kind of a survey to be done.
And so that was one of the aims,
at least of the paper,
was to draw together
all the different threads, to unify them,
make them a bit more cohesive and
and present the free energy principle
as we're conceptualizing it today
in a very top
to bottom fashion.
Though, before we jump into the sections
and the arguments
and the claims in the paper, which I'm
sure will cover a lot of these updates,
I'd just love to hear
what is the free energy principle,
what is active inference,
and how are they related?
I mean, I guess
in the most general sense,
the free energy principle
is a statement
that says that we can understand
the dynamics of self-organizing systems
as following a path
of least surprising
in the most general sense.
And then in that context, it's good
that you ask the question.
I think that there are at least two
uses of the term
active inference in the literature.
The one that I tended
to use is a very broad sense,
which is just like active
inference is specifying
a path of least action
for what are called autonomous states.
So like the active
and internal states of systems
that are considered
things under the free energy formulation.
Active inference is also been used
to refer to a class of specific,
partially observable
Markov decision process models
that have been deployed,
and most of the implement
in Silico implementations
of the Free Energy Principle.
Rely on these and I think this has led
to a little bit of confusion
in that, you know, when folks say
active inference is a general theory able
to account for self-organization.
They're not they're not saying
this specific class of pump
models as effectively, you know,
repurpose people for everything.
So, yeah, I would say that
this is the first sense that I outlined
is the sense in which we say that active
inference is a corollary
of the free energy principle.
And yeah,
I mean, in its most general form,
the free energy
principle is just the statement
and an alternative statement
or a restatement
of the principle of stationary action.
Where the action is defined
as a surprise will
in effect.
Great.
Dalton, same questions to you.
Yeah, I think Max pretty much covered it.
So as I mentioned, you know,
my background is actually not in the
free energy principle, not originally,
and it's not even in machine learning.
So I have come at this literature
with a bit of a different set
of ideas and traditions and tools.
And so as a result,
I can't really talk about
active, intrinsic,
and I'm not totally familiar with it,
but I can talk about the free energy
principle at length.
I'll try to be brief.
So to me, the free energy
principle is a statement
that random dynamical systems
do on average unsurprising things.
And and it's a very simple statement.
All it means is that
if you have a random dynamical system
and it's trying to get
to some place in state space,
that is not surprising to it.
So some preferred region of state space,
maybe a particular phenotype, maybe
a particular morphological blueprint,
something like this.
The free energy
principle is a statement of
not only that that happens,
but also a set of tools to model
how that happens, how the systems
get to these kinds of attractors.
And there is this very interesting way
in which the
the getting to that attractor
can be read as inference.
And this is where these
all these connections in literature
appear to things like active inference.
You can talk about how systems actually
get themselves to that attractor
as a perception of action problem,
and you can model it
using this very famous
variational free energy bound,
and you can show, okay, when the system
is encoding some sort of belief
about its environment and about itself,
when it does this inference,
you have the minimization of some upper
bound on surprise.
So. So the system is at least doing
unsurprising things at the level of
its not exceeding some kind of
intrinsic surprising
that some of the early formulations,
some of the more recent formulations
take it even further.
And you say the surprise of full stuff of
of some trajectory of the system
is going to be minimized by the system
that's going to take on average,
the system is going to do what
it expects to do, which in this case is
get to some region in the state space
that it prefers to inhabit.
What makes that not a tautology
and what makes it something
that we can actually operationalize
and ask interesting questions about
is the fact that there
is this nice connection to inference.
There are all of these explicit
mathematical tools
that we can use to talk about
surprise and minimization,
not just as the kind of information
theoretic statement of systems
that aren't surprising,
but systems that aren't surprised
do unsurprising things that ends up
a little bit more nuanced than that. And
so so to me, the free energy principle
is this whole host of results about
random dynamical
systems
and especially random dynamical systems
which are organized
or which self-organize.
I think that is
how I would think of it.
And it's and it's got some physics and
stuff
that that we can actually talk about
in that context. Awesome.
Thanks both for those great answers.
I'm pulling up the paper
and so many things in what you said.
I just wanted to follow up on.
But let's follow the main
line of the paper.
And wherever you think
there are some dots
that could be connected or any questions
arising or areas of future research
or the connection to applications
that you're working on or other people
might think about getting involved in.
We can just take those little cul
de sacs from the main line.
So I have the paper up
on Bayesian
mechanics, a physics of and by beliefs.
The two of you are the first authors.
There's also Connor Hynes, Magnus Coote,
all Baron Milledge,
Lancelot, D'Costa, Brandon
Klein and Karl Friston.
Any just overview notes on again
like what led to this team
or anything like that?
While we're on this first page, well.
From my perspective, you know, Dublin
and I have been talking a lot about this
kind of stuff for the last year, year
and a half, two years.
And yeah, I won't I won't try to.
I'll try not to be too
overly General Skelton, but I think.
Yeah.
So some of Dalton's work has,
I think, changed
the way that we think
about the FFP in particular.
We worked with Dalton late in this great
paper towards a geometry and analysis
for Bayesian
mechanics is to show that the free energy
principle
and the principle of constrained maximum
entropy are actually dual to each other.
They are two sides of the same coin.
And I you know, I've been
I've been following this line of work
for quite some time.
And I think it's foundational
really changes
the way that we think about the ATP.
It moves it from like this,
some might say exotic result
from theoretical neurobiology to,
you know, it connects it back up to
the foundations of contemporary physics
effectively by showing that,
you know, this thing that we understand
and almost take for granted,
you know, maximum entropy inference
procedures turn out to connect up
to this free energy
literature in a non-trivial way.
So I think the paper started out
and it didn't end this way,
but I think we started off trying
to write a reader friendly companion
to the work that Dalton had done,
but by the end
of it realized that this was more,
I think, Dalton's paper towards geometry
and analysis for Bayesian mechanics.
I think it stands on its own
as a piece of piece
of mathematical reasoning.
So it is an exercise in maximum entropy,
inference, math,
and it shows that you can recover
some of the really core results
of the free energy
formulation, just using the language
of constraint, maximum entropy.
In particular, Dalton approves
the approximate Bayesian inference
lemma that had caused so much discussion
in our literature
for the last bit.
And so, you know,
I think the paper grew out of that.
And yeah,
the team is something of a who's
who of like the, you know,
the core contributors to this literature.
And it just from a strategic
point of view, it was important
for us to have like,
you know, allowance to Costa.
Karl Friston, you know, Connor
Hynes and folks that had been,
I think, contributing
to this core formulation
and in particular to the development of,
you know, this new framing
of the free energy
stuff of Bayesian mechanics.
So yeah,
I think that the paper grew out of that.
And if Dalton's paper is this Dalton's
stance
towards the geometry and analysis
for Bayesian
mechanics is a kind of standalone
piece of mathematical reasoning.
This is more about how this actually fits
into the free energy
principle literature.
So this is very much more a free energy
principle at a richer paper.
And yeah, we
were hoping to do as reader
friendly and introduction as we could.
There are actually two whole kind
of introductory sections in the paper,
but we ended up doing a lot of,
I think, important work
in that paper, connecting up
to the free energy principle.
I hope that helps. Answer me.
Great answer and welcome.
Lars, would you like to give
any overviews or notes before we jump
into the sections of the paper?
Hey, thanks.
Thanks for sending me the link
there. Mexican.
Allow me on here.
No, nothing really to add there.
I'm just
here as a spectator of a few questions
as we go down along and maybe concurrence
of the conversation.
But yeah,
thanks for having me on. Awesome.
All right.
So the abstract begins
with a really clear aim.
The aim of this paper is to introduce
a field of study that has emerged
over the last decade
called Bayesian Mechanics.
And we're going to be unpacking
that claim.
So suffice to say, the abstract
very clear and summarizes
some of the core points
that we're going to delve into now.
We're looking now at the contents.
So what led to the sections of the paper
being this way
and in this order?
What did you feel like
it was important to include?
it was important to introduce and why?
Okay.
Well, so if you look,
I'll actually pull it up in front of me
so that we were all talking
about the same thing
to me. 1/2
and it's viewable in large size
on the live stream.
So yeah, feel free to have your own copy
up, but I'll have whatever section
we're looking at
will be very visible in the lecture.
While.
Maxwell is grabbing his copy.
I'll just give a couple
of contextual remarks.
So, so like Maxwell
described, I mean, originally
I had
released this set of results about what
we call approximate Bayesian inference.
And so the mathematical basis
for some of the key ideas
in the PHP literature
up until that point anyway
and originally
it was meant to be a much shorter paper
that just dissected some of those results
and related them back to the SDP
in a way that was a little more concrete
and a way that people
who actually work on the ACP
might might care a little more about.
Because of course,
the stuff that I wrote about is
a little far removed from the SDP, even
though it's an object and inspiration.
So the results in in that paper,
there is a reading of that paper
where it's formally pretty
distinct from the it. And
so so originally
that was the goal is to just give it
some extra physics intuition
and some extra connection
to the actual ethics.
It became something a little bit
different as we were building this out
and we realized, okay,
there are a whole set of new results,
not only mine, but also from Carl
TMB Group and from others folks.
And they all really should be tied
together nicely.
And part of that is the connecting
the geometry
and analysis paper to the actual FEC.
Part of it is actually talking about what
we would
think of the ACP as today
that shaped the table of contents
a little bit
because a lot of what we
then wanted to go and say is, okay,
we have this theory
of the free energy principle.
One of the key
ideas in the way that we're viewing
the free energy principle today
is that it is just a bit of physics.
It is it is much like classical mechanics
or statistical mechanics.
It has a set of mathematical results
that sort of hang around it, that
give it a nice foundation,
and it applies to specific systems
and describes them in a specific way.
And that was why we began
with both an overview of
what is mechanics, what do we talk about
in physics when we say mechanics?
And also Section three is
what is the free energy principle?
What have we talked about
so far in the literature
and what might we define
as Bayesian mechanics?
So what is what is the physics of beliefs
or systems that carry beliefs?
So that's sort of excuse me,
that sort of shaped
the first maybe 20 pages of the papers.
It's just building out the theory
and the context for the theory
afterwards is
a bit of a sort of change in
our line of attack.
But but you'll see
it does remain very similar.
So I won't get too far ahead of myself
or. Any other notes.
Maxwell Or we can carry on.
I think that's a, that's a great summary.
I think.
Yeah, we, we try to keep
this as self-contained
as possible as a paper.
So, you know, the two
introductory sections are meant to
provide some kind of visual
intuition
for a lot of the more formal results
that are discussed in the paper
and in the papers that it builds on.
We have, you know,
the artistic brilliance of Brennan
Klein was added to this paper.
So, you know,
I think the the illustrations help.
The idea was that,
you know, based on Dalton's work,
we are formulating
basically a geometry and analysis
for the core results in the three energy
principle literature.
So we thought, let's leverage
the geometric nature of a
lot of these intuitions
to really illustrate them.
And so, yeah, that I think
explains a lot of the structure
and the paper ends on some philosophical
considerations and hopefully clarifies
some of the confusions
or misunderstandings, understandable
misunderstandings that have arisen.
Yeah.
So I think that that does really address
I guess the last thing to point out
is we introduced this
field of study in the last section
that we we call G theory,
which is,
I think, the direction that we're going
to be moving in for a while,
which is formulating
the free energy principle
and the Bayesian mechanics
in terms of maximum caliber. So
extending this duality between
the density dynamics formulation,
the free energy principle in terms
of probability densities over states
and maximum
constrained maximum entropy
to paper based formulation.
So past entropy installed caliber
and you can
Dalton is one of the world
specialists in maximum caliber
and the maximum caliber is a maximum
path entropy.
So it's the same idea as maximum entropy.
But you're
considering the entropy of paths.
And we have had, you know,
the free energy principle started off
as formulated in terms of path.
So after all, it is a version
of the principle of stationary action.
It leads us to write down
paths of stationary action.
And so the the ambition now
is to connect these things out
much more formally so that we can
we can handle really genuine
non equilibria, things like wandering
marks of blankets and moving attractors
and all that kind of stuff, which find,
you know, a home
much more naturally in the language
of maximum caliber than you did.
You want add anything to that, Dalton?
You're really the max cal expert.
No, I think that's
that's a good account of one of the key
future directions is,
you know, we spend the first half
introducing Bayesian mechanics.
We spend the second half talking
about where Bayesian mechanics fits
into the rest of statistical mechanics
and high energy physics
by connecting it to max sense
and to gauge theories.
And this is where
some of the geometric stuff comes in.
And then that the very last thing we do,
we sort of cap it off by saying,
okay, now, you know, we've talked a lot
about Bayesian mechanics.
We've talked a lot about Axiom
entropy, Bayesian mechanics.
But there is in some sense,
much more natural formulation
of Bayesian mechanics
in terms of dynamics,
because ultimately that's what
we're thinking about is dynamical systems
and the way that they evolve in time
where they flow over their state space.
And there's there's a sense in which
not only is
it much more natural mathematically,
it just works easier.
It looks prettier.
It's it's it's much nicer.
There's also a sense in which it's it's
meaningless
to talk about states of a process
which is constantly in flux.
So limiting
ourselves to densities of states
as exists in the last
couple of years of the literature,
which has in fact
not always been the case.
Some of the early stuff is written
in terms of generalized
coordinates of motion,
which are nothing but a particular way
of talking about dynamics
and therefore paths.
So there's a sense
in which the recent detour into states
is very limiting, not only mathematically
but conceptually limiting.
And we can see that directly
in the way that it is
handling things like non
microbial processes
or processes that change with statistics
that are out of equilibrium.
So, so that the at the very end we say,
you know, we've done all this work
that the best next step
is to take all of this
and, and all of the stuff
that we've just done about maximum
entropy based mechanics
and put it in dynamical terms.
And this necessitates
passing to what we call Maxim caliber,
which is also due to James originally.
It's the principle of path entropy,
but eventually, you know,
the goal is
we be able to write all of this stuff
and in particular
we'll be able to generalize
what we have written into a language
that's much more dynamical.
And and Max Carroll, we already know,
has demonstrated
an immense success
in treating non-equilibrium processes.
So mathematically, I mean, there's reason
to be very optimistic about what
we will gain when we generalize
that duality that we've talked
about previously.
And so it really does seem like it's it's
the ideal thing to do
in the very near future.
Awesome.
Let's jump into the sections.
So section one is the introduction
and just one part
that I wanted to highlight
that the footnotes are so informative.
There's some of these motifs
like we set out to make it as simple as
possible in four pages was our limit,
but then we ended up innovating this way.
So that's one funny motif.
And then the other funny motif
that I see is
the super informative footnote.
Often because maybe it's possible
to just make the claim
standalone
and in direct response to somewhere else.
So that's very exciting and interesting.
Like footnote one covers
a lot of the prerequisite fields
like dynamical systems theory, calculus,
probability and information theory.
So I found that to be very interesting
because it helps us understand
where we can come from
and what kinds of backgrounds
we'd want to be learning about.
And then also a very important
distinction
of the two meanings of the word belief
in the probabilistic sense
of Bayesian statistics
or the propositional or folk
understanding as you write
from philosophy and cognitive science.
So I just thought those were
two interesting footnotes and reflected
like part of the process
and the discourse around the primary text
and how that can be clarified
in this format.
Feel free to make any overall comments
on that or that's
just getting to page three.
Well, about the prerequisites,
it's a it's a difficult
it's a difficult balance to achieve
in some sense.
Right, because we don't want
to be academic gatekeepers.
No one benefits from gatekeeping, but
these are also highly technical fields.
So, you know,
I've been joking for the last few months.
If you've never taken a derivative,
you're going to have a bad time
in this literature.
It's just not the kind of thing
that lends itself to,
you know, surface engagement
in some sense.
Like, it's very and especially with these
these new developments.
I mean, there's Dalton's work
that basically shows that the free energy
principle is dual to maximum entropy,
maximum and calibrated.
So there's this kind of deep connection
to, I mean, effectively
the core of contemporary physics.
And there's these
there are these new results
that show that the free energy
principle is asymptotically equivalent
to the principle of unitary
from quantum mechanics.
You know, the, there's,
there are these new quantum
formulations of FP that have popped up.
So yeah, I mean,
navigating the space
comfortably presupposes a lot.
And the good news
is that it's hard for everyone.
So there's, there's
something to learn for everyone.
You know,
I'd spent the last three years of my life
teaching myself like category theory
and gauge theory and stuff,
which turned out to be very useful,
you know, connecting up with Delta and
doing all of this work.
But now we're launching ourselves
into quantum theory, which I'm less
familiar with.
So there's something
to find difficult for everyone.
But yeah, it
I really do think that
to fully appreciate
going on here,
some technical prerequisites
are important.
Otherwise we're led
to making false assertions.
Like I seem to circulate a lot
that dynamical systems approaches
are contradictory
to information theoretic approaches,
which is just nonsense
from a formal point of view.
Information metrics
naturally reemerge
when you're considering, for example,
how do you measure
distance and state space effectively?
It's just yeah.
So the, the more mathematical background
one comes with,
I think the easier it is to integrate
into this.
Yeah.
Yes, well, indeed, there's
a lot of encouraging and good news
and hopefully a community
that also values
participation and accessibility as well.
So agreed, important general points
there.
Yeah.
Before we move on, I'll say something
really quickly about this.
Just because it's it's a remark
that's actually pretty important to me.
And in fact, Max
was the one who wrote it, but
I didn't even realize.
But it is an important clarification
that when we talk about beliefs
and inference,
it's it's much more general than just
an agent or a cognitive object.
The manner in which
we talk about inference and we talk about
carrying beliefs
is this this much more general sense
of just two random dynamical systems
that are coupled
and and therefore reflect
the statistics of each other.
So it could be a set
I mean, generically, this is a system
estimating the statistics
of an embedding environment.
The very important point is any system
with any noise
and in fact, systems
with no noise have statistics.
And so any system that estimates
or couples to another system
with statistics can be interpreted
as mathematical inference
that one system performs
inference about the other.
The the sort of content that you place on
that idea of inference
is very case dependent.
So it's not the case that that so it's
for instance, a cognitive
but it is very much the case that stones
reflect the statistics
of their environment simply
because these two systems are coupled
and their statistics reflect each other.
And so this is what we need
in the sense of talking about agents
that carry beliefs
simply is about objects that do this
kind of statistical estimation,
which we think of as inference.
But it's certainly much more general
than simply
something like a reinforcement learning
agent that actually stores
representation of its environment.
It is a representation, but in a much
more trivial sense, in a general case.
Mean I would
I would add to that by pointing out
that, you know, Galton was saying that
there were there were disadvantages
to focusing on the density
dynamic formulation which features
Markov blankets and the like.
So markup like are great
and we like them.
But I think focusing on them
so much in the literature
over the last several years has obscured
the fact that
the free energy principle is at core
a statement about how, you know,
as Dalton was saying earlier, random
dynamical systems coupled to each other.
So, you know, the Merkle
blanket is not something I often hear
and read in the literature,
the markup when it gets to clouds
the organism from its environment.
But it's not
that's not that's not the idea at all.
The Merkle blanket is the set of states
via which the organism
and its environment are coupled.
And in fact, we,
you know, we made this case in a paper
on a variational approach
to this construction several years ago.
You can basically swap the sensory
and active states
of your organism and you get sensory
and active states of an environment.
It is fundamentally a story
about how systems couple
and synchronize each other.
It's not a story about how,
you know, things that exist
are somehow secluded from an environment.
It's really a story about how,
yeah, we, we, we,
we become a model of our environment,
meaning that we are in tune
with, engaged with and reflecting
the structure of that environment.
This becomes very clear, by the way,
when you look at the quantum formulations
of the free energy principle.
If you take the asymptotic
limit of the free energy principle
so its behavior as time
tends towards infinity
for classical systems
that have space time individuation,
what get is something like
the good regulator theorem.
So I become as much as possible as I can,
like my environment, you know, modulo
the space time separation.
I can't be my environment because
I'm here, it's there in some sense.
And then what you get in that context
is the statistical mirroring.
But in in the quantum context,
when there is no space
like separation
between systems, the step tends
towards entanglement.
So systems
that are related in an FP theoretic way
at the quantum level become entangled.
That is precisely what the FDP does,
conforming to the fact
that systems become maximally entangled.
So it really is not a statement about,
you know, how organisms separate
from their environment.
It's a statement
about how organisms are things
in general self-organizing
systems, individual and couple
simultaneously to their environments,
how that's not a contradiction.
Excellent.
So as we rush through Section
one and head to Section two,
I just wanted to pull out two really
key quotes you wrote in this paper.
We discussed the relationship between
dynamics, mechanics and principles.
And then later on page five,
you write, Bayesian mechanics
is specialized for particular systems
that have a partition of states
and go on to describe it more.
So as we head towards Section two,
an overview of the idea of mechanics
and indeed Bayesian mechanics.
Could you unpack a little bit
by what you mean
dynamics, mechanics and principles.
Sure.
So no. Andrews as everyone,
I think in the literature knows now
wrote this great paper.
The math is not the territory
which challenged us to be very clear
about what we meant, really,
when we're talking about free energy
principle and active inference.
And then there
I think
Mel makes a number of contributions,
but one of their most important
contributions is to differentiate between
the 50 as an uninterrupted
formal structure and the P
as it might figure in applications
to model specific kinds of systems.
And now points out that the
a lot of the confusion
in the philosophical literature has to do
with the fact that the primary literature
often doesn't differentiate between
the just
a mathematical structure of the theory,
and then these models interpreted
as representing certain features of
the target system
that we want to make sense of.
And that's important
because falsification
or verification, empirical validation
more generally
applies to one kind of thing,
but not the other, right?
So the three energy principle, insofar
as it is a mathematical theory
like a formal statement,
is no more falsifiable or subject
to empirical verification than calculus
would be like you wouldn't you wouldn't
try to falsify the axioms of calculus.
They do or do not apply in formidably
to certain kinds of systems.
So there's a level at which
the core formal results of the figure
have that status,
their mathematical results.
And we can use this to
do some interesting empirical stuff.
So what we wanted to do
is to differentiate
between three kinds of formal things.
In the first class of tools that
no was outlining.
Namely, we distinguish between dynamics,
mechanics and principles.
So the dynamics are descriptive.
They are basically a formal description
of some systems behavior.
You might say that like Galilean,
mechanics is almost entirely dynamics.
You needed someone like Newton
to come around and say, Well,
there are general equations of motion
that one can write down to account for
sort of how these
how this description
plays out in some sense.
So we move from dynamics to mechanics
in the same way that we move
from description to explanation,
from a target phenomenon
that is formalized in a certain way
that we would like to have an explanation
for, to a set of equations of motion
that really account for
how those dynamics come to be.
And then principles in mechanics
tell you how principles tell you why.
So usually in physics
we appeal to some symmetry
or conservation principle
in order to derive the mechanics
or the mechanical theory
for the systems in question.
So what we're left with is principles,
mechanics and dynamics,
all of which are formal theories.
And once you have the mechanics,
you can apply it to study
specific kinds of systems empirically.
And that's where
the empirical verification would come in.
So principles are not falsifiable,
they're just bits of math,
and you use them to write down
mechanical theories, which,
when interpreted in the right context
and when the variables are mapped on to
things
that are of interest target systems,
then they become subject
to empirical evaluation.
So hopefully that, you know, clarifies
a lot of the model
around it, around the FFP.
One of the reasons why we spent so long
outlining the idea of mechanics
and physics is that this isn't
some exotic way of thinking about things.
This is really just physics,
just straight vanilla
reasoning from physics.
Yeah, I'll stop there.
Nelson has probably some
interesting things that I
not know.
I think. Think you've covered it?
Yeah.
It's it's just that there are important
formal differences in physics
between what we would call
the mechanical theory for some object
and a dynamical description
of some object.
And so in this tower of things,
you get ideas,
you get theories that sit
at different layers in the tower.
This hierarchy ends up being useful
in clarifying
this host of different results
in the app
and where one fits into the other.
So it was important.
Take the time to discuss it, but
that was that and that's the whole point
of Section two.
Awesome.
So to also move quickly through
Section two on page nine, you're right,
we are concerned here
with what
we have called Bayesian mechanics.
And then you launch into an example
of mechanical theory, operationalizing
a mathematical principle, and you provide
some classical statistical
formulations on page ten.
So could you give us an overview of what
the equations on page ten are showing
like, what they do for classical physics,
and what is the analogy
or what is the connection
that this is preparing us
to make with Bayesian mechanics?
Yes. Well,
in fact, I have an entire paper
that's about to come out about this,
just like building on the analogy.
So I'll leave that as an Easter egg
for the audience.
Watch out for a classical physics
for the Bayesian mechanic paper.
It's, I think, instant classic.
It might be some interest.
Yes, might be of some interest,
but yes, on page ten,
we are just giving an example of the
of this kind of formal difference.
So you have some kind of principles
in classical physics.
It is the principle that systems
are kind of lazy, you know,
they there is some kind of
an amount of energy
that it takes to get from A
to B, and systems
don't waste that energy.
So they take precisely the shortest path
from A to B or the path of least energy
in in the more technical sense
of the transfer
of potential energy into kinetic energy.
So if you have some amount
of stored energy, the transfer of that
into energy of motion
is minimized along the path.
That's a very
abstract statement, and there's not a lot
that you can actually do
with that computationally.
All you can say is, you know,
systems systems try and get from A to B
using the shortest amount of motion
possible, no extra motion.
So so if you see in FIG.
one, for instance,
there are these parts that fly off into
sort of these very strange fluctuations
in the classical world.
Those fluctuations don't exist
because classical systems
take this energy
minimizing parabolic path.
And in the dark blue,
what is computational about that?
Is that principle of stationary action.
So the principle that you don't waste
energy
results in a mechanical theory,
a law of motion
for the mechanics of classical objects.
This is what we would call Newton's law.
Newton's second law in particular.
It's this Everyone knows F equals
M, it hits
force equals mass times acceleration.
So the idea is that
if you are such a system, if
you minimize the amount of energy
that you take,
then the acceleration of you
must obey precisely
the force being applied to you.
And and so this is your
your law of motion.
This is a mechanical theory.
The dynamics that come out of that
are able to be discussed
when you start putting in actual details,
when you plug in whatever force
being applied.
Sorry, that's a dog.
You probably heard it.
What is what is the force
being applied to the system?
What are the initial conditions
for the system?
What is the mass for the system?
All of this extra data
that's giving you trajectories.
So an actual model of the system which is
less explanatory and more descriptive.
And this is at the very bottom
of the hierarchy
where you get this dynamical theory
that's got all this extra data in it.
So this is this is very quickly
an account of the that hierarchy.
Awesome.
Let's move into section
three and figure two.
So the caption is three
phases of Bayesian mechanics.
What are the three of Bayesian mechanics
and what is this figures showing?
Well,
it's it's often been suggested
that there are like 17,000 versions
of the free energy principle
and that it's not very clear
what the current version
is and all that stuff.
And some of this is fair
and some of it is
I think some of it is fair
because it is true
that often in the technical papers,
not sufficient care has been given to
making very explicit which assumptions
we're making about the systems
that we're interested in modeling.
So what we tried to do in Section
three is to provide
a comprehensive survey of all of the ways
that the free energy
principle
has been articulated in the literature.
And so it
turns out that there are basically three
main ways in which the FFP is applied,
which were representing here.
So we've already alluded
to the first distinction.
The FFP can either be formulated
in terms of a probability density
overstates directly or as a probability
density over paths,
so over trajectories of states
that we write in
so called generalized coordinates.
And those are importantly different.
So the literature over the last I guess
like circa 29, 2012 to 2019 focused
almost exclusively on the density over
states formulation.
And this is where you get
the approximate Bayesian inference lemma
that's played a pretty critical role
in a lot of these investigations.
This is also where you get
like states that play the role of Markov
blankets effectively,
whereas the original
formulation of the FFP was in terms
of probability density over power.
So you're not, you're
not really so much interested in, in
the dynamics of
the system, just in terms
of how probable that states are,
what you're actually interested in is,
you know, entire trajectories
that unfold over time.
And the the most general paths
formulation doesn't make
a lot of the assumptions that have been
criticized over the last little bit.
So importantly,
we don't assume the the systems
being described are stationary.
We don't assume that,
you know, and accordingly,
we don't assume that the system has
a non equilibrium, a steady state.
And we're
now returning to this formulation
because it's less restrictive,
you know, for reasons that
we should probably detail
better than I can.
So then
within the density overstates formulation
and what you get is this kind of mode
tracking or mode matching behavior where
I mean, essentially
what we're saying is that a system
that conforms to the free energy
principle is such that it looks
as if the average internal state
is tracking the average external state or
matching it.
And the relevant difference
in that density overstates
formulation is that the external mode
that the system is tracking
can have dynamics to it or can also not.
And it was important to distinguish
these cases
because a lot of the formal analysis,
so for example are calling in Sussex
released this great paper.
How particular are the physics
of the free energy principle?
And they come to the conclusion
that there's the act doesn't really have
anything to say about the class of system
that they examined.
What is the class of systems
that they examined?
They are looking at linear systems
that undergo dissipation effectively.
So physically
these are damping springs, right?
So to restate,
if you take away the mathematical
baggage, what they're saying is the Fed
doesn't have anything
particularly interesting to say
about the behavior of Dandan Springs.
So what does a damp spring do?
Well, it starts off
and then it dissipates
back to a fixed point being
just through the friction.
So the mode towards which the system is
flowing has no dynamics to it.
It is a fixed point.
It just dissipates back to a fixed point.
And what they're showing is
that there is nothing interesting to say
from an FP
theoretic perspective about the system.
But I mean, the counterpoint
that's sort of there isn't interesting.
Anything interesting theoretically
to say about the systems,
there isn't any interesting
external dynamics
that the internal dynamics
would be matching.
And a lot of these null results,
we use FP technology
to say stuff about a system
and there's nothing interesting to say.
Look at systems that have fixed
modes, fixed external nodes.
And so, you know, the the idea
is that the ATP applies virtuously
to those systems because there's
nothing interesting to say.
So yeah,
to, to summarize my, my rant, we,
we tried
to summarize the main applications
of the FTT in the literature.
We identified three and strategically
we point out where some commentators
may have been led astray
by focusing on one rather than the other.
So in particular, a lot of this,
these ideas that the FTT
can handle things like, you know, systems
with moving attractors and systems
that don't have like a single mode,
that these are understandable
characterizations given that basically
since 2000, from 2018 to to the 2012
to 2019, we mostly focused on this middle
class of systems.
So systems that we're describing in terms
of the density of states
that have a dynamic mode.
So it's understandable why people would
focus their attention on that.
But the FFP in its most general
form doesn't make, you know, perhaps
problematic assumptions like seasonality.
And it yeah, it also applies,
interestingly,
to systems that have interesting
external state dynamics.
So strategically, I
think that's what we were going for
in this section.
And then I believe this is the only place
in the entire literature where
this is reviewed so comprehensively
in terms of this tripartite distinction.
So, you know,
I don't mean to be disingenuous
and to suggest that the confusions
that have arisen are only due to,
you know,
just the lack of paying attention.
These things have not been expressed
very clearly.
The assumptions have not always
been stated very clearly.
And yeah,
the the form of the path of least action
in each of these things
looks very different.
So we can also understand
why it might seem like
there are 17 versions
of the three energy principle,
but there are.
Thank you, Maxwell.
As we speed through this section,
I'll just note that formalism
one on page 15 is familiar
and has to do with the flow of states
in the particular partition.
And we've also seen the Helmholtz
decomposition shown in Figure three.
In terms of a decomposition add on
into the vertical and the horizontal
that the gradient pursuing
and the solenoid or ice contour
or aspect of flow,
those are reviewed in the citations
that are provided here.
So let's get into the newer stuff.
In Section four, you're discussing
some mathematical, mathematical
preliminaries on the maximum entropy
principle gauge theory initialization.
But first, yes, last.
For moving up
the stage of work is a section
three was incredibly.
Illuminating for me personally.
I think the literature in general.
Having the separation out and
there was a question that arose for me
and working through this
that I just want to throw out there.
I don't want to distract the journey
through the paper too much.
But in moving to this,
you talk about on page 19,
when the FFP is applied to density over
states as opposed to,
we assume a non-equilibrium
steady state density.
And then on the next page, page 20,
you see we can view this
mass non-equilibrium city state density
as providing a set of prior
preferential preferences
which lead the particular system
to look like it attempts to enact
and bring about these preferences
through action.
If you then move
to the path based formulation
where there is known as assumption,
how do you recover these preferences
in in that formulation?
Or can you not use that formulation
to describe systems
that are doing actions
that look like better preferences?
Or is there a piece that I'm missing?
Does it make sense?
I can take that one.
So one of the one of the key
deliverables of this third section
is this three faces type thing, right?
So the idea of the free energy
principle and,
and the mechanical theory
that arises from is we would want a
mechanical theory,
a law of motion for Bayesian inference
or for systems that do Bayesian inference
and what it ends up
being is approximate Bayesian inference.
And this comes in three flavors load
matching mode tracking or path track.
This is the three phase system.
So that I mean, just like you have
different flavors of classical mechanics,
you have things that move continuously,
like satellites in orbit,
or you have things that move
and then start moving
like a ball thrown through the air,
eventually returns to the ground
and things that sit on the ground
don't move unless they're acted upon.
So there are very different flavors
of approximate phase influence and these
three are particular the kinds of things
that we're thinking about.
So the reason why I give that context
is because we can still
imagine preferences
on the paths of a system.
A system must evolve
in such a way that it avoids
certain areas of the state space,
given that it remains a system.
So, you know,
a human can
evolve in such a way that it dips too
far away from its other static bounds.
That's a set points and set
and bounced around those set points
in which I can oscillate
but too far outside of those bounds
and I'm in trouble.
Likewise, you know,
I can have something like a stone
that kind of evolves
through a state space.
The stone doesn't have preferences
per se, but it has a definition.
And so we can read not
preferences, but definition is about
what a stone looks like
in the same sense
as we understand what a human looks like
as certain preferences
that guarantee cohesion.
So the things that are definitional
of a stone
guarantee
that same kind of cohesion that just
there's
a type error if you would identify them,
but that, you know, mathematically they
they end up looking very similar.
And what's interesting about that is now
you can talk about preferences
or you can talk about definitions
along the path of evolution of a system.
Stone must stay roughly together.
It must stay
in this sort of crystalline structure.
If you start hammering away at it,
you turn it into a power.
This is something that we wouldn't
think of as stone.
So so in the same sense, if a human
doesn't eat for too long
and maybe starve to death,
it's it's a really grim example,
but unfortunately, it's
one of the better ones you can imagine.
You know, you're
you're drifting too far away from this
state of being satiated
or having sufficient energy
to maintain cellular
processes and the chemical reactions
that sustain life.
And as a result,
you know, the preference along
your set of paths has been violated.
So I think, yes, there is a sense in
which even though we have foregone a mass
density per se,
we still have a density of a over paths.
Not all the states that this density
still expresses
something of a definition for the system
or a set of preferences for the system
without which we don't have
a conceptualization of that system.
That's
that's a very long answer to a question.
But maybe it satisfies, you.
Know, that's that's great.
Thank you so much.
That was really useful. That makes sense.
Thank you.
You can kind of think about it
as these constraints force systems
to basically pick trajectories
that are at the trial of, you know,
a preference landscape or a constraint
landscape if you want to think about it.
So you get the same kind of thing
as Dalton was saying.
But it's not the systems aren't
assumed to be stationary, so they're not,
you know, non-equilibrium
steady state distributions per se.
But there is something analogous
and a lot of the future work in theory
is precisely about
using the technology of maximum caliber
to really make sense
of this formerly.
So let's move.
Into section four.
So in Section four, as noted
and as referenced
to the previous publication,
even there's a discussion that the FP is
dual to the constrained
maximum entropy principle.
And then one of the ways
that that's pursued in this section
is through the lens,
or at least related to gauge theory.
So we're looking at figure four.
What is gauge theory?
What is category theory?
Dual and how is it being deployed
in this situation?
So I guess I'll take that one as well.
Figure four You said yes.
Okay.
I'll illustration of fiber bundles.
Section two, big mego figures.
Oh, yeah.
Okay. Yeah.
Well, mega figure.
I recognize that name.
I believe that's how we referred to it
internally.
Yeah.
Well so
if you ask me
because I am a mathematician primarily
if you were to ask me
or if you were to ask the mathematician,
what is the gauge theory, you would
probably get a response roughly.
Like what gauge theory is the study of
a particular geometric
space called a fiber bundle.
So there is there is a type of space
called the fiber bundle in geometry.
It looks exactly like that figure.
It's a bunch of fibers pasted on to
something on the bottom,
what we call it, based on a boat
and and studying how these things
behave in a space like this.
How do they behave in the sort of fibers
and how does that reflect
some kind of behavior
on the basement? Folks,
these are interesting
geometric questions
that arise in the study of fiber
bundles and hence
and what is called gauge theory.
If you're a physicist,
I mean, it turns out that a fiber bundles
are the natural space.
We're talking
about classical gauge theory.
So the theory of certain high energy
particles.
But it's but it's a little bit
more general than that.
And so if you're a physicist,
this is what you think of.
You think about
like gauge photons, but this is only
because fiber bundles are very natural
way of talking about these slits.
And so it is a little bit more general
what we're talking about in the figure
four is this idea that
in this space of fibers,
you can kind of trace out surfaces
and that these surfaces are like
probability densities
over the baseline of thought.
And in fact, they are just like
probability densities, they are.
So you can formulate probabilities
over a state space
as an object in a fiber bundle.
And therefore,
if you
have all the technology available to you,
you can draw this very nice case
theoretic interpretation
of what it means to be
a probability density and therefore,
because the object of Bayesian
mechanics is systems that do inference
and so systems
that estimate probability densities,
there is a nice stage
theoretic interpretation
to Bayesian mechanics
that hinges pretty much on this picture.
What we would call the gauge
in this situation
is choice of this J function.
So you see you have several
different surfaces,
three of them, each of which comes
with a different choice of j.
So the, the idea
of choosing a function in the fibers
and therefore choosing
a shape for your service,
this is what we would think of
as a gauge theory.
And that's why
I went down this route
in the geometry and analysis paper,
because it ends up
drawing a very nice picture
of what it might mean to
engage in constrained inference.
Awesome.
And could I give a pedestrian or
so the the bystander the yeah.
The, the more, the less technical
version of it is to gauge theories.
And Dalton, correct me whenever
I say something that's wildly or even
not so wildly inaccurate,
but gauge theories are basically
how one would how one articulates
a symmetry is are conservation
laws and contemporary physics.
So most physics relies on the idea that
some transformations
that are of interest, like the ones
described by Maxwell's equations,
have some kind of symmetry
or that concerned.
A slightly better way of going about
it would be to say that,
you know, modern physics is broken up
roughly
into stuff and forces
and forces act on stuff
and stuff gets acted on by forces.
So the
interesting thing in theory is
you can talk about
how a definition of some stuff,
the shape of some stuff
is intimately dependent on the forces
acting on the stuff.
And so this is where we get this idea of
we have a particular shape
to our surface.
We have some,
you know, probabilities over our states,
but that this is actually defined by the
the the choice of gauge
this this j function.
So our assignment of probability
to states is actually determined
not by probability, but it's determined
by the constraints on those states.
Certain states are preferable.
Certain states
not on preferable states get low
probability
preferable states get high probability.
And our notion of ability
is encoded in the choice of j.
It's a function
that constrains different states.
And so constraints in
this case are like penalties.
That's our assignment of penalties.
So our choice of force is actually what
shapes our assignment of probability.
That's ultimately,
I think, well, that's
a slightly different way of viewing.
The geometry of the situation is serious
all about these kinds
of what we would call
covariance relationships,
covariance meaning literally two things
burying together.
If I choose a force, I'm
forced to choose some stuff.
And likewise, if I choose some stuff
that necessitates
an underlying choice of force.
So gauge covariance
ends up being very helpful
in situations like this.
Thanks.
Let's see if we can touch
on some of these last figures.
In FIG.
five, we see a vector field on a curve
that's reminding us
of that sort of baseball diamond shape
from earlier with a path of least action.
And in Fig.
six, a probability density is generated
by level sets of the constraint function.
J So either figure five or figure six,
whichever you feel
fits in best here, what is being shown
and where are you going with it?
How is it connected
to alternative phrasings?
Yeah, I guess I'll just cut to FIG.
six, which is kind of
about this covariance thing.
So if I choose
a particular functional form for J
in this case it's a penalty
that is proportional to distance.
I would expect my assignment
the probability
to fall off roughly a distance function.
So it should.
It should.
The probability of a state
should decrease
as the penalty on the state increases.
So in this case, the probability
of a state should decrease
as I go away from some central point
and it should do so symmetrically.
And so we would expect
a Gaussian density from this.
And it is indeed the case
that you can understand the covariance
as a kind of projecting down
and then lifting back up.
And what do you get when you do that?
Well, the stuff in the equation,
the probability
ends up being defined by you.
We take of the sort of rings
on the j function.
You protect them down,
you get circles on the base manifolds
when you lift them back up their rings.
And so we know a symmetric
probability density
with a whole bunch of rings
is just a Gaussian probability density.
So, so this figure is kind of capturing
what does this covariance relationship
actually look like?
How do we actually build stuff
out of forces?
And it ends up being the case that it's
this very simple recipe of you
push everything down and then you lift
it back up and the lift is E to the J,
so the you place J on to X,
that's the first step.
Your second step is then you hit it
with this exponential function and e to
the minus x squared is
of course a Gaussian density.
So that's all that Figure
six is depicting.
It's just zooming in
on one of the objects in FIG.
four. Great.
And I thought on page 34,
also the striking result
that the splitting
of the flow of the system
into vertical and horizontal components
under the constrained maximum entropy
principle is ice and morphic
to the Helmholtz decomposition
of the flow of the autonomous partition
of a particular system.
So for those who are caught up with
the way that the Helmholtz decomposition
was used, for example, in the papers
that we discussed in Live Stream 32
with Markov
blankets and K stochastic chaos,
this is augmenting it or transposing
it into another formalization
and moving on again quickly.
It's worth pointing out that there is
there are some significant advantages
to reformulating things
in terms of maximum entropy.
I'll I'll I'll let you know Delta
and speak to the more technical
parts of this but I guess one
one thing that pops out to me
more politically is that
maximum entropy
and constrained maximum entropy.
I mean, they are just core parts
of the physicists toolbox.
So the fact that we are able to reproduce
the Helmholtz
decomposition
in terms of the way that flow splits up
in the gauge theoretic formulation,
I think is quite significant.
It gives us an entirely independent line
of reasoning arising at the same results.
So, you know, especially due to some
some work by Martin Beil and colleagues
a few years ago we were not
we were no longer sure
whether some of these results obtained.
You know, there had been doubts thrown on
to the derivations
of the approximate
Bayesian inference lemma in some papers.
Life, as we know is
from 2013, I believe, is the paper
that they targeted
one way of reading this
is that independent
of all these analyzes, independent of
whether Beil and colleagues are correct
about their criticism of the 2013 paper,
this is an independent derivation
that just follows
from uncontroversial mathematics.
And we're able to re re derive
basically the main core
portions of the formal results
that Carl derived,
the approximate Bayesian inference
lemma, the Helmholtz decomposition.
And I mean, in some sense,
the magic is that we understand
now why these arise to begin with.
There's yeah
I think that the
the maximum entropy interpretation
in some sense, especially in the gage
theoretic formulation
in some sense tells us,
well, why, why does approximate
Bayesian ex-friends work just full stop
and these sets of results explain
effectively why this has to be the case.
Only my facilitator hat
prevents me from being excited.
Section 5.4 also explored
more in the previous citation.
So the four things that I wanted
to just touch on as briefly
as people wanted as we close
are the three philosophical areas
that are introduced in Section six
and then of course just the appetizer
of G theory.
So page 38, Section six,
The Philosophy of Bayesian Mechanics
6.1 addresses clarifying
the epistemic status of the FP.
So what were you aiming to bring people's
attention
to and address in 6.1
with this philosophical question?
Well, I think this basically summarizes
the point about dynamics,
mechanics and principles
that we were making earlier.
So the ACP has been described
variously in various
and sometimes very different ways,
even by its core.
Proponents of Carl introduced
the FP to the world as a theory
of cortical function circa 2005
and then as a unified brain theory
in 2010, which led a lot of people.
And I think not to say this is in bad
faith, it led a lot of people to say,
well, okay, so this is a theory
and so it should be making predictions
and therefore
it should be empirically verifiable.
So I think that the way
that we talked about it
led to a lot of confusion.
And it's been described as a framework,
whatever that means by myself
included, right?
So now, Cooper,
we called it the active inference
framework for a long time without really
being specific as to what that meant.
We kind of let all this
this cluster of results,
that kind of agglomerate around the
Rajah and
colleagues have called this a a trick,
kind of like the variational auto encoder
trick in machine learning.
So it's a it's a trick
if you can write a bar code blanket
for a system that you can make,
you can write down a model that looks
that says that the system looks
as if it's performing.
Bayesian inference.
It's also been called
a physics of physics, of safety
and systems of formal ontology.
So the point is to,
so everyone is kind of right,
you know, these are all in some sense
valid assessments.
And Mel was really the one
who clarified things
initially, I think, by distinguishing
formal structures
from interpreted
empirically available models.
And yeah I think that the first part here
is to say, well,
we can make sense of this model
by appealing to this
tripartite distinction
that we've outlined.
So by distinguishing dynamics,
descriptions, formal
descriptions of some behavior
that we want to get to, mechanical
theories that explain how the principles
that explain why, and then
what we're calling, I think, empirical
applications, which are basically
these formal models plus
an assignment or an interpretation
or evaluation of these models in terms
of the features of folded systems
that we want to explain.
Yeah.
So when they're applied
in that really mechanical theories
become empirical theories
as we write in the ordinary sense.
But yeah,
so hopefully this time to clarify
as everything around falsification,
how this thing is used and importantly
why this is just standard physics.
I mean, this isn't
this isn't all that spooky
in terms of the use of mathematics
to make sense of physically relevant
aspects of our universe.
So that's what we were trying to do
in that section.
Great.
Really clear. 6.1.
It reads to me
like it's the tip of an iceberg
with a nice landing and take off strip.
And yes, it's a big iceberg,
but it is an iceberg
and there is a tip that makes sense.
6.2 On page 39, Ellen Goodall and the FP.
What does the French linguistics
have to do with the FP?
Maxwell
Well, Dolphin might have some pretty
interesting remarks to make,
but just briefly, I mean,
I find it kind of ironic that,
you know,
the people who are most critical of
right now, like folks
from the inactive tradition and folks
from the ecological tradition, sometimes
frame their own research, is trying
to, you know, struggle against dualism
in some sense.
But our belief is that they are
intrinsically dualistic frameworks.
So a lot of detail is a French term
with vitalism.
I don't know how familiar you are
with the history of biology,
but before the 20th century
and the discovery of DNA, most serious
physicist believed in something
like Aristotle's into intellect
so that you had to have some kind of
physical mechanism for purposes in this.
And a lot of detail
was this kind of vital force
that they believed the vital skills,
animated living systems
and differentiated them from
non-living systems like stones and rocks.
And we believe that one
of the consequences of the perspective
that we're adopting here, building on the
especially the work of Mike
Levin, who's done amazing
made amazing contributions in this field,
is that it?
Self-organization and cognition and life.
And these these things that we like
to point out as being distinct from inert
matter
are actually are more on a continuum.
You know,
the Bayesian mechanics says that
basically anything that's a thing
will exhibit some features of what
we think of as cognition.
So it is a massive,
massively deflationary
and absolutely resolute,
humanistic perspective
that we're advancing here.
Yeah.
Which just, you know, the trying to look
for the boundary between living
and non-living systems is bound to fail.
In some sense there is a continuum.
These processes
that we're interested in are also events
by rocks
and by tornadoes and by crystals.
And it is a question of degree
to which systems act
as cognitive systems.
Yeah,
I'm sure GJELTEN
has more interesting things to say about.
Yes on 6.2.
What else would you add there?
Dalton Well, maybe not more interesting,
perhaps more interesting things to say.
But. Well, yeah,
I mean,
I think this section is as mostly just
a recapitulation of footnote
two in a sense,
meaning, you know, we made this statement
that inference per se, a representation
of some statistics of something else
is this very broad.
The general and any system
that is not a closed
system does inference.
So what that means is, you know, under
the free energy principle, at least what
we've written in that paper,
you know, what we've worked out so far,
there isn't
a way to talk
about cognition versus non cognition.
It's more of a spectrum of cognition.
There are certain systems
that are more competent.
This is something
that Carl might call a temporal depth.
So there are systems that are very good
at planning and executing actions
and there are systems
that are not, you know,
so there's a very clear difference
between humans and stones, for instance.
But that difference isn't in
one does inference and another doesn't.
It's that one does
a bit more complicated inference.
It has
better
or more accurate representations
or more representations.
Full stop. Maybe.
And it's better at using
those representations to to do action.
But both stones and humans are estimates
of the statistics of the processes
around them
simply by mathematical construction.
And so there's this very
uncontroversial statement,
or at least it shouldn't be a controversy
that systems things
in the very most general sense
exhibit this kind of representation based
inference that we would
typically identify as cognition.
So that was the motivation
for talking about that.
And then Maxwell tied a very nice
bow on it with this great history
of a debate around
very similar questions.
But yeah, it was this idea of a
of a spectrum of cognition.
Awesome and citation 92
there is the 2018 paper
answering Schrodinger's question
so many years ago.
The other Maxwell at all,
who raised that question
and sparked really
a phase transition in the discourse.
And that was also like one of. The
it was.
One of the papers that really drew me in
and got me excited.
And so it's amazing
to see what other questions
and answers have been risen 6.3
And then gee,
so 6.3 is a slightly longer section
and it's on maps and territories.
So yes.
I'm I'm really glad, I'm really glad
that we were able to write this. So
I never found
this particularly confusing, but I it
it has led to a lot of confusion.
In particular,
there's this entire paper by Thomas
Linus that just is just confused about
this issue.
I forget what it's called this
living life model or what.
Anyway,
so folks have said, well, so
is, is the free energy principle
just just a description
that we are, you know,
a model that we are
using to, describe
interesting features of the world.
Or is it saying that
in a self-organizing systems
actually we are models of the world.
And so, you know, we I never particularly
found this problematic
because I took
this this phrase in the paper,
I think sums it up correctly,
is that the free energy
principle is in some sense a map of that
part of the territory
that looks as if it is a map.
And so
Thomas Metzger
actually retweeted our paper and pointed
to called this nested representation
within which I found interesting.
So yeah, there are these kind of
two distinct levels at play,
but there's no foul play here
because the FFP model is very explicit
about
which parts of the formalism pertain
to our map of the territory
and which parts of the formalism pertain
to the map.
The self-organizing systems
constructing according to our map.
So I think it's important to point out
that there isn't a contradiction here.
There
owns just these two probability densities
that are at play in the construction,
the density and the density.
And you can understand
the the generative model
or the density as basically
our of the self-organizing system
in terms of joint probability density
over state space
or potentially it's a space of paths.
So in that sense, you know, the
the self-organizing system
being its own best
model really means we have a model,
we can explain the systems dynamics
and the the system's
potential is formalized,
you know, as a as a generative model,
a joint probability density.
It just so happens
that part of the variables
that are described by that joint
probability density
played the role of parameter sizing,
additional probability densities
over another subset of variables
described by the generative model.
So there are really these two, I think,
unambiguously different
senses of being a model that are at play.
And yeah,
I don't think this is a sleight of hand
and hopefully we have clarified.
Yeah.
What, what exactly is at stake here.
I think there are some nice connections
to the maximum entropy formulation.
So as the Delta articulated in the paper
at least
and I know you said you said
as much in discussion today, I think
buy it by flipping to the perspective
of maximization of entropy.
We we effectively recover
our own position
as modelers trying to model the system.
So the the prison through maximum
entropy is adds
this additional clarification that
yeah we can entirely recover
the perspective of a model
are using maximum entropy modeling
to model a free energy type system
by invoking this duality of perspectives.
And I think that's really important.
Then there's this other piece here
which says that the the maps
that we construct in FFP
and in Max and both adhere
a kind of epistemic minimalism.
So maximum entropy inference
is basically saying, I'm going to
or given some data set
the probability density the most that is
the one that best explains the data set
is the one with the highest entropy.
What this means is that
we are building in to that
probability distribution
as little prior information as possible.
It's like starting from the point of view
of maximal ignorance.
Given a few constraints,
what is the underlying probability
density of the FCB
as a similar starting point for?
Maximal ignorance,
which says I can't go beyond the blanket.
I am stuck with the data
that I'm generating and with the way
that I probe the world, this data
generating process to generate my data.
And there is no going beyond that.
You can't go beyond the blanket
unless you break the blanket,
but then you're just introducing
the new blanket.
So, for example,
I can't see in your brains,
I could put you in an MRI machine
and break the blanket,
but then I'm introducing another
another blanket,
which is this new set of data that I have
to continue making inferences from.
And so, I mean, then the the max
and kind of emerge as these epistemic li
minimal or
you know, they kind of emerge
as the way that you would construct
a map of the part of the territory
that acts as a map from, a perspective
from a starting point
of maximal ignorance.
Right?
And I think that's connected
in the active inference textbook
to figure point one,
the meta Bayesian perspective.
And there it's not described
in the context of maximum entropy,
but it's something very similar with this
nested representation journalism
on any other philosophical notes
before we go to Section seven?
Yeah, that's exactly right.
That's exactly right. Yeah. Yeah.
I love.
This book.
Yeah.
That anything to add
before we want you to get there?
No, I think you raised an
interesting point so we can talk about,
you know, when we use the P
to model a system, what we're doing is
forming a model
of the system where the system forms
a model of its environment.
And so there is
this nested representation with them.
What's interesting
about the maximum entropy
point of view is you can kind of
do allies is if you can, you can take
the sort of mirror image of this thing
and you can ask, okay, well,
we're not interested
in a model of the system
modeling something.
All we want is a model of the system.
So what does the system look like
when it's creating that model?
Not what does the system's
model look like?
So this this is the dualisation
aspect of things.
And so you can talk about what
and when you do allies,
you can talk about things
like constraints on agents, states
rather than the predictions
and actions of the agents.
So it's a bit of a different viewpoint.
It's just emphasizing different
levels, the nest, so to speak,
which is which is kind of interesting
because you do get both
of these perspectives for free
as soon as you commit
to this relational symmetry
of an observer in an environment
and an agent in an environment,
and how those two things do
model each other.
And that's what you get when you do
aligns things.
That's, that's, yeah, that's,
that's it for me on that section.
I think Max looks pretty much covered
a lot of the important points.
I mean I will say this,
this probably is not obvious
until you look at the mathematical
formula issue
and notice that there are two
you know, as I as I wrote
in that paper from a few years ago,
the FP is a tale of two densities.
And you really need to like
take a look at the math two, understand
that there isn't a
this isn't like a case of reification.
This is just formulated.
So it it isn't that so simple
that you could just put it in directly
to the graph and say,
Hey, look, here are these two.
But definitely
if you take the time to work through
formalism, there are clearly
these two different senses
of being a model
that are at play,
that are cleanly distinguished
and I think are actually not all
that problematic.
Awesome.
It's almost like thinking
through other minds highlighted
some of the social consequence
and theory of mind and behavioral aspects
of certain types of cognitive entities.
But systems
thinking of through about other systems
or infers
thinking through other infers inference
that type of dual view from the inside
view from the outside is again
what you're suggesting is enabled
by that kind of a commitment
to this foundations and of course
it could be a whole nother gas stream
and perhaps should be on G theory.
But as we close here, what can we say
today on 613, 2022 about G theory
and what is exciting you all about
how you're going to continue
forward?
Do you want to take this one? Dalton
Yeah, sure.
So, I mean, like I mentioned earlier on,
there's a lot of really promising stuff
in the literature
about path integrals and path entropy
and the kind of power
it has to deal with systems
that we would normally kind of balk at.
And and so it's already very promising.
There's reason to be optimistic
about how this extension
will benefit us in the future.
So G theory itself is an actual coined
this term to describe the extension
of this duality
from mode matching and max sense
max cow,
which will involve precisely this.
We'll try to formulate the free energy
principle
in its full generality as dual
entropy, and it's full generality
on paths and so forth.
And so the reason why this
is so exciting is because
there's a
very clear path towards talking about
systems
that are non stationary, so systems
whose statistics change
more complicated forms of inference,
more complicated forms
of constraints and preferences.
And so it seems like already
it's a much more faithful description
of the kinds of systems that we want
to talk about and extends to things like
more complex systems, things
like humans potentially.
So so this is really the,
I guess the, the end goal
is to do this dualisation to now build
an f, e
t dual model of something like a brain,
which we know models its environment
in this very complicated way.
And so the kinds of representations
it does are, very complicated.
So how do we model that, that
that should arise out of maximum caliber
and therefore out of theory?
And in principle,
eventually we'll have a very faithful,
very foundational
picture of complex systems.
But this is a very long term
goal in the short
term,
we just want to get the math to work.
To connect that a bit.
To Morris's question earlier,
what does it mean to have a non
stationary density over this?
Well, I mean, what we're interested in
is the way that the density changes
as a function of the dynamics
so that you really have like these moving
surfaces over a space of paths
or a space of states.
And to really capture
all of that kind of time dependency
requires moving from max to max cow
from states to paths and
all of these kind of more fine grained,
you know, wandering blankets
and moving attractors
and all of that good stuff
should fall fairly naturally out of
gear theoretic formulation
of this stuff.
I like how within FP as we know it,
we have variational free energy f
and then expected free energy takes us
into the future and planning and that's.
G And then we see a little bit of like
free energy principle F
and then G is the next letter.
So that's a funny little
would no dual analogy.
Well,
if anybody has any closing thoughts,
it would be a great time for that.
But just wanted to say that there's
a lot of appreciation in the chat
and a lot of excitement around this work.
So we hope that you just continue
acting and inferring serving.
That's that's kind of you to say,
yeah.
Thank you very much
for the invitation to discuss our work.
This has been great.
And yeah, we,
we look forward to exploring the future
with this whole community
and thanks for your time.
Our attention and your energy are very,
very positive.
Always a pleasure to be on Active Lab.
And yeah, thanks for the guest.
Sorry.
Yes, I can only echo that.
It's been a pleasure. So thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you, Maxwell and Dalton at all.
Thank you, Lars, for joining.
And until the next time. Bye.
Made the gradient descent ever
in your favorite method.
And with yours slash rs. By.